in Saudi Arabia oh my god wow Saudi girl
no American American Girl from Alabama
whoa yeah well dude no you said I said
your sister what she no he was saying
she was cisgender there's nothing sacred
she was sister she was cisgender thank
you and that was that's very important
yeah wow how old was she
she was 25 years old what no she was
also 14. 14. the both of you yeah oh God
in love with that was your girlfriend
wow loved her for two years after that
would write letters back before he had
emailed guys huh you'd write a letter
and she put a perfume on it get out of
here and I would go and I would miss her
and then and then and then the rest is
downhill from there well you guys broke
up
yes oh no
yeah because she was a turkey
I thought it would be a love story she
was in turkey and I was in America oh
yeah right so I couldn't it's very
different yeah is it awkward if you see
a woman come in with a full burger and
you think it's your ex well you know
what by the way I think a lot of women
are in flesh burkas and that's our
society what does that mean that means
that as a woman you've got to put on a
[ __ ] load of makeup and get all your all
your surgeries and [ __ ] that to me is
worse than having to wear a [ __ ]
something you can take off the amount of
pressure it takes to get this [ __ ] going
and that [ __ ] going and that surgeries
we have a culture that doesn't make
people feel good about themselves oh so
product by telling people you have a
deficit oh wow like you could change
this yeah bring this up a little bit
Yeah and women have to compete because
my favorite bit I've seen in a long time
is Bill Burr's bit about how no feminist
has watched one [ __ ] w NBA game uh
yeah I was making all the [ __ ] money
or are the Kardashians who who basically
look the exact same now yeah they've all
looked the exact same yes thank you to
their fantastic doctors yes but that's
where the money is [ __ ] yeah you
have to have a bone structure that cuts
light well and if you don't we got the
technology to fix that you just need a
lot of money I don't think so yeah I
should feel good I did didn't make I
mean I think you look [ __ ] amazing
thank you very much I really think it
was great it was a great decision
seriously yeah oh that's good that's my
natural look if I relax my face go
no no I know I keep it tight are your
lips natural huh your lips
I've never done any filler in my in my
face and I've never dyed my hair you
said in your face have you gotten filler
elsewhere I mean here this is obvious oh
yeah wait in this area yeah yeah
San Jose Improv this weekend
mccann.com
the comments have been amazing but I
don't read one comment my girl told me
oh wow it was like Adam good having a
girl that lies to you when I did
bro I did [ __ ] when I uh complicated
my special before this Adam Carolla told
me it was the highest rated [ __ ]
podcast on I mean comedy special on
Apple and I never read one [ __ ]
comment really because I'm afraid of
comments because the same power that a
good comment has a negative comment yeah
yeah yeah so keep it uh just keep doing
your work man yeah I can't do it I'm too
sensitive yeah really saying that you
guys don't read no that's that's a Brian
Callan thing because the minute you
[ __ ] you you get seduced by the
public Embrace you're gonna start aiming
if they tell you you're something and it
feels good you're gonna aim for that and
if they tell you and then then somebody
one person is going to say it's like one
person it's like it's like um I had an
acting teacher who said you don't go
home for the holidays and they're like
what the [ __ ] and he goes because you're
gonna have a sister or your mother is
going to go you haven't made it yet huh
my prayers aren't being answered yes oh
so God doesn't want me to make it either
and it would [ __ ] them up for six months
I saw that in real time what's crazy is
that acting teacher also didn't make it
and didn't see his family so that
[ __ ] is miserable